because you're stepping into what's a
very iconic
and very British franchise aren't you
you're stepping in to bond with Skyfall
it was absolutely the most magnificent
experience I've had in my life and you
know in a year working with directors
like some Anders and Victor Strickland
is absolutely a dream come true and I
feel incredibly lucky I'm really
grateful how does it feel to join the
ranks of actresses like Halle Berry and
Ursula Andress and so so many more on
though I can't really put it together in
my head just yet
but it feels wonderful and that's one of
the reasons why I chose to be an actress
and to be a part of this dream and this
magnificent
atmosphere that films have and how much
it takes to create the film and bring it
to life and especially being a part of
such a huge history is absolutely
wonderful really really grateful and
tell me which which your favorite Bond
movies and which of your favorite Bond
actors and actresses well I've always
been a fan of Bond films and I really
liked Sean Connery I really loved Daniel
Craig as bond because he's very human
and he brings a very human side to it
and I mean the actresses that have been
Bond girls are absolutely magnificent
you know from Halle Berry to all those
wonderful women that are iconic that
have been in the past so I think you
should treat every film as something it
as an individual so especially all the
Bond films everyone has its own history
and they're like beautiful diamonds all
of those
was it like working with Daniel Craig
he's absolutely wonderful he's one of
the loveliest human beings I've ever
worked with and he helped me very very
much and I'm really grateful to him and
to some mentors they were absolutely
wonderful he's very human very normal
and very nice he's a gentleman he's very
nice and the scenes that you have with
him can get quite steamy called a I
really don't know no idea I mean is it
difficult to do that kind of stuff as an
actress or you just have to think this
is my job now I think in general it has
to do with with the partner like if I'm
not helping the actor opposite me and
he's not helping me then it's
uncomfortable but if you sort of you
know breathe it's never very comfortable
of course
but we depend really on the player what
was it like working with Sam Mendes a
great director
he is absolutely fantastic and of course
like everyone on the planet I've always
admired his work and I you know he's
such a great human being and he's so
inspiring
such an amazing amazing vision and films
wonderful
you